what has been the one thing plague in
Counter-Strike since its Inception well
yes anime profile pictures but more
importantly cheaters forget Integrity
cheaters straight up ruin the goddamn
game and for two decades the problem has
only gotten worse but if the leaks are
true valve might have finally devised a
solution to the problem vac live
okay it's no small secret that CS go has
a cheating problem for years it's been
ruining our ranked experiences and for
just as long it's felt like valve didn't
care enough to do anything about it but
with the announcement of Counter-Strike
2 and subsequent leaks it seems like we
are finally getting a solution to the
problem in the form of an enhanced
anti-cheat the question is will we have
to sacrifice our own privacy for more
Integrity in our games well to answer
that question we first have to go way
back and talk about the history of
valve's anti-cheat systems when you hop
into an online game whether it's casual
or competitive there's only two things
you really care about fun and fairness
unfortunately there are those who have
made it their life's mission to obstruct
your enjoyment as much as possible
okay what the is this guy on
it's usually
on console look at his Aimbot
he's shooting left the bullets are going
right
he trying to look over here
is he on your body
yeah what
uh I think I died Peter now toggling God
mode and giving yourself unlimited cash
in a single player game could be good
fun but it's hard to wrap my head around
what gratification comes from hacking in
an online Lobby however we're not here
to unlock the psychology of cheaters
that's an entirely other video what we
are here to talk about are the measures
the developers have taken to prevent
these people from ruining our online
experiences and one of the earliest
versions of anti-cheat software was
developed way back in the year 2000. as
the story goes after getting tilted by
cheaters in the OG Team Fortress Tony
Ray developed Punk Buster an anti-cheat
software that went on to be used in
countless titles including some
well-known Half-Life mods however valve
having developed the majority of popular
online games realize they should
probably create their own custom
anti-cheat to fight against the growing
issue and in 2002 vac was born now the
Wayback worked was pretty cut and dry it
would run multiple challenges and scans
to test and see if someone's PC was
running cheats if a known illegal
application was being used that's a
layup if not valve Engineers would have
to go in and manually determine if the
application running was in fact cheats
when a cheater is found they are given a
vac ban and prohibited from playing on
vac protected servers forever which is
why getting banned is now lovingly known
as evacation
[Music]
no
Thursday no unfortunately things aren't
that easy as you can expect anytime a
cheating application is found out
another one just pops up to fill its
space for that reason valve's cheating
problem has persisted across two decades
and a multitude of games and as CS go
blew up to become an FPS phenomenon the
problem reached an all-time high Mike do
they still want you to watch a demo
oh
wait we have script
okay he doesn't give up anymore dude
I was having fun
okay now as I sort of alluded to I don't
think it's all valve's fault any game is
going to have a cheater problem to a
certain extent and if there was another
fps to have as much success for as long
as the time as CS go did I'm sure we'd
be making a video talking about that
game instead that being said it doesn't
excuse the existence of the problem and
with all the Goddamn money they've made
off of us you'd think that valve would
have come up with a better solution by
now I mean this is pretty much the only
game where professional players have
been caught cheating live and banned
multiple times you know that Buddy says
he does not exist it's just simple on
his own lone wolf with the awp he's out
in the Russian Wilderness just sniping
did Emilio just get vac banned
what
but experiencing a cheater isn't just
annoying have it happen to you enough
and you might just end up having
psychological effects back in 2014 CS go
experienced its first vacanting everyone
became paranoid and started pointing
fingers at each other and a similar
thing happened by December of 2018 when
600 000 players were vac banned in that
month alone and since the explosion of
the player base in the last few years I
feel like we've just gotten to that
point of paranoia again sure when you
get insta One Tap by running AK there's
probably a lot more plausible
conclusions you should come to whether
it be network problems or a skill issue
but the fact is there are a lot of
cheaters and that's always going to be
sitting in the back of your head and
honestly valve can get if they
actually think I'm going to use
OverWatch and do their job for them now
it's not all hopeless because in 2020
Riot of all companies developed
controversial albeit effective
anti-cheat for valorent
Vanguard you see Vanguard was extremely
powerful but it came with a catch that
just didn't sit well with a lot of users
it downloaded alongside the valorin
client and existed on your PC 24 7. but
I think they went way too hard here I
mean this anti-cheat has access to all
your I wouldn't be surprised if it
started pulling up your SAT scores
mid-game just to shame you in front of
the other players or pull up like
embarrassing family photos or something
it has way too much control now since
the original outrage over the
invasiveness of Vanguard players have
mostly come to accept it for starters
Riot wasn't going to budge so it was
either live with Vanguard existing on
your PC 24 7 or
don't play valorent on top of that it
was seemingly very effective and as an
added plus Vanguard wouldn't just detect
cheaters after the fact and save your
ELO it would save your time as well by
canceling the match right there and then
and if you're someone like me a CS go
player who probably doesn't care about
their privacy as much as they should I
would willingly take a problematic
anti-cheat if it meant that it would
work now this is where we get to
Counter-Strike 2 and the future of its
anti-cheap before the announcement of
valve's next title there were a ton of
things that valve die hards were
expecting to get in the new iteration
and above all the graphical and gameplay
changes people were mostly looking for
two things a better matchmaking system
and a working anti-cheat now while
there's not a ton of information on what
valve is going to do to fix our
matchmaking woes a leak does suggest
that we are going to be getting a new
anti-cheat system that might have
similarities to Vanguard vac live what
is vac live you ask well that's a little
hard to answer but judging from the name
and the line of text we got from the
data mine my best guess is that it's an
anti-cheat system that actively detects
cheaters and cancels the game as soon as
a hacker is caught there are but a few
questions is that going to work like
Vanguard and boot up with your PC and
never turn off and if so are players
going to be okay with that like I said I
would be welcome to this new change is
it good for my privacy or online Freedom
no but as it sounds I'm willing to give
a bit of that up I'm just not sure if
everyone else will be too but my best
guess is the answer will be yes people
did it with Vanguard and everyone seems
to be fine right now hell I'm pretty
sure there's some of you watching right
now who have Vanguard running and have
an open valorant in months like me and
who knows I could be wrong maybe Val
finally took all that case money and put
it to good use and developed an
anti-cheat system that is only on when
Counter-Strike 2 is on
it's entirely possible all I'm hoping
for is that the leak is true and that
back live is a real thing because as
we've seen already if it's not we might
be in some trouble
cheating imagine dude he's hacking in
the CS2
oh my God
play with an actual cheater no way wow
oh this guy who's this guy right here
who's this guy right here
Waits
that being said let me pass the question
off to you guys are you okay with an
always-on anti-cheat system if it means
you can be more confident in your
outcomes or is this a deal breaker
I was watching Pimp's stream the other
day and he made a joke about how they're
gonna add shoes like they added gloves
to Counter-Strike now that you can see
your legs
[Music]
and I wouldn't put it past them
look at knee pads
Jorts
imagine that Jorts
how much would George cost probably like
a cool 10K depending on how many got in
box yo what's the what's the pattern
yo the drawers are a pattern-based skin
what pattern did you have oh I got five
two five two one no dude